eight Washington liquorway bounce Aiden
truck on the sledgehammer oh having
words to A.D
are you taking it personally well I'd go
if I'm 80 I got to go right back at him
give me the ball 84-4 in the quarter
three
knocked it away Reeves is down
whoa and knocks over ayton he sure did
they had words earlier
he's straight leveled
Deandre ayton
and he Beverly is upset because the
officials would not call when DeAndre
ayton was standing over Austin Reeves
and he took offense to that because they
wouldn't call it so he took matters into
his own hands
that is exactly what happened
that should have been an immediate
taunting foul
by DeAndre ayton when he was standing
over Reeves
now watch the whole play here here's the
block shot
by Devin Booker
[Applause]
I'm not sure that wasn't a foul
[Applause]
wow
the Fishers are used replay to determine
if there's a hostile act or physical
alteration that did not resolve after
the foul
[Applause]
oh there certainly was a hostile Act
[Applause]
oh man that is a straight body check
there by Beverly to ayton
now certainly Beverly is going to be
gone
there's no excuse for that I will say
that but why he did that is because he
was standing over Austin Reeves having
words with him
[Applause]
a personal foul was called on Booker
[Music]
when Reeves went down they did call a
foul on Booker
oh my goodness
now this happened even before before
this play happened at the other end when
deandreatin
and he was talking noise to Anthony
Davis and then and then he and then they
were drawn yes and then the play that
came down was this play right here
so this has been going on for a while
look at this
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a lot to sort out here
well you cover football a lot what do
you think about that
well it was uh in the NFL they'd be
hitting a defenseless receiver yes it
would
but I think
what you said has Merit in that ayton
was standing over the Fallen player and
not leaving in a timely way and Beverly
took exception to it
yeah Patrick Beverly already knows he's
going to be thrown out so he's walking
back to the locker room now
that's an easy call he wants to get a
good seat on that flight to San Antonio
after the game
yeah but that can result in something
more than just an objection I agree
there's a suspension behind that
so here's the replay
see I think this is what the officials
are looking at as well it's right here
the taunting by DeAndre ayton over
Reeves
that might be a technical foul on on
Deandre ayton
for the taunting
which led to Beverly body checking him
oh man that's hey am I My Brother's
Keeper a pun review
the file is sent Devin Booker it's a
flagrant foul penalty one
patch we have double technical fouls
Patrick Beverly has been ejected for the
physical time
[Applause]
received two shots and the Lakers will
see the ball on the side shotgun stages
24. we're good let's go
and Devin Booker with the technical foul
with the smack to the face